voilà je joue c'est qu'elle extrait du
nouvel album de louis bertignac qui
s'appelle longtemps voilà c'est pas mal
du tout alors j'ai appris un truc louis
en lisant cette émission c'est que vous
êtes né en 54 à oran et que votre père
ça c'est énorme avait en charge la
maintenance des juke-box de la ville
ouais c'est vrai c'est incroyable ça
c'était bien pour moi parce que je n'y
avais les dix tout de suite si j'avais
un mange disque et enfin je les recevais
des qu'ils étaient un peu usé mais il
sautait pas encore trop vrai c'était
génial bien sûr mais il a fait plein de
job super mon père qu'est ce qu'il
appelle d'autres il a importé des trucs
du japon les trucs à 2 300 balles à
l'époque et c'était des talkie walkie
des mini cassettes les premiers trucs
qu'on n'avait pas encore enfant dray
fait que j'arrivais en classe avec des
talkie walkie c'était magique
je parlais à mon copain autre bout de la
classe sont peu proches le sache
vos premiers émois musicaux c'était le
rock'n'roll que votre père diffusé dans
l'émission je pense me souviens pas mais
moi ça devait être choc berry bill haley
tous êtres humains et après vous avez
été effectivement très marqué par la
période 1960 1973 donc toute la pop
anglaise de la fin les années 60
et vous dites depuis la créativité
général est tombée aujourd'hui on est
dans la distraction la distraction chez
pas sévère qu on fait ce qu'on peut
les musiciens font ce qu'ils peuvent il
y avait c'est sûr qu'il y avait une
émulation incroyable je suis pas quoi
c'était du entre une envers ce qui le
même truc qui a fait que
68 à vidéo c'était c'était une émulation
incroyable je sais pas pourquoi il ya
plus à aujourd'hui j'ai enfin il ya eu
tellement de belles mélodies à l'époque
c'est pour moi un nom assez un texto
c'est ma fille bonne nuit eldad union
j'ai encore raté mon bac les foules de
gens bien non oh non mais celui-ci n'est
pas seul c'est ça qui veut te dire a
lancé des messages multimédias mais je
ne prends pas anciens modèles de
téléphones aubanel mais la récession
là aussi un ouais
j'ai bien téléphone par rapport à tous
ces groupes qu'on adore téléphone ça
tient la route un jour là il a bien
bossé on a bien bossé ouais c'était à
monrovia j'aimais bien les autres et on
était sérieux ont déconné pas trop 1re
formation alors non jamais mais si tous
les français faire mariner 30 en concert
avec pour un concert de tête ouais mais
c'est délicat j'avais essayé en 2002
remettre tout le monde ensemble
vous détestez non pas du tout au
contraire alors j'ai réellement une
grande histoire ensemble mais tu sais
que dès qu'on essaye de faire un truc
tout de suite très bien un truc
commercial énorme ça gâche un peu le
plaisir pas fait ça chez vous et puis
n'en parlait pas ben on veut fait